je vous présente le pied de caméra d'aujourd'hui puisque j'ai oublié le mien et parait
que c'est comme d'habitude
eeeeh! HA HA HA HA HA!
Attention ça, ça peut rester au montage.. Non..nan! Salut! Aujourd'hui
je suis avec frédéric alias
le "mythologue"
La mythologie? Non c'est le mythologue? Non c'est heu... c'est le mensonge
donc on traite du mensonges dans sa
généralité
de la détection à la compréhension des
mécanismes des rires
car comme vous êtes pertinents vous
avez compris que c'était
d'une chaîne youtube dont on parlait
chaîne  youtube euh je vous la met dans la description mais on y reviendra à la fin
alors déjà merci de venir ici dans les bureaux
c'est pas le..c'est pas mon..
mon décor habituel de la maison parce que
je travaille des fois .- c'est sexy!
je fais croire au gens que je travaille .-rire.- .-bafouille un peu-. Ca a de la gueule en tout cas!
C'est un faux décors! Frederic tu viens de Bruxelles en plus?! Absolument!
Absolument je suis belge du coup je risque de dire
septante au lieu de soixante dix et nonante au lieu de quatre vingt dix .- alors pourquoi t'es là
parce que ca vient de la vidéo
à la base sur Trump- ou on avait discuté avec pleins de
personnes
dont toi, sur des choses qui n'allaient
potentiellement pas
dans la manière de voir
enfaite l'information  .- c'était pas la vidéo sur
Hollande?
ah oui mais c'était pour le discours de
trump! C'est ça! Exact!
enfin lors de l'élection de Donald Trump
enfin l'élection.. on s'entend
et  huuuumm
et donc suite à ça j'avais proposé de faire une vidéo - tout à fait- et
t'as répondu présent et j'en suis ravi .- mais moi de même-.on ne va pas se taper
dessus je suis désolé par contre pour ceux qui
s'attendait à ça c'est
surtout une uneuuu  une
une belle occasion pour pouvoir discuter
d'une manière ..bafouille..
trouver les sources de vulgarisateur peut-être sur le web de comment toi tu vois les
choses par apport à ta chaîne
qui est sur le mensonge donc au tant te dire que sa m'intéresse j'étais un des premiers à m'abonner à
avoir mis un p'tits commentaires .-c'est vrai! c'est vrai c'est le premier-. à
m'avoir dit bravo
d'ailleur sur la chaîne .- tout à fait-. je vais commencer par dire deux choses
la première je suis pas venu pour taper
sur fabien
je suis pas venu pour vous le dézinguer et vous le
vous le vous le butter au final de la vidéo
et la deuxième chose est que ce que je
vait dire
ne représente pas une vérité ça
représente ce que je pense
d'un point de vue scientifique .- voilà.-
comme ça on est tous d'accord
Ta vérité? ouais c'est  mes
certitudes on va dire
c'est plutôt mes certitudes
donc mon point de vue c'est que je suis linguiste je Dr en psycho donc ma vie tourne autour de la science enn général
et l'idée c'est que pour moi
il n'y a pas de grandes vérités
il n'y a que les choses qu'on peut
appréhender ci et là
il ya une méthode pour les appréhender
si on se base que sur l'observation pour
moi au risque de
d'être victime de biais c'est à dire
des petits raccourcis qui font qu'on va
se tromper
par contre .- et si je  peut me permettre pas apport au mot biais d'aller aussi vers se qu'on
cherche
absolument! absolument! tout à fait!
tout à fait! c'est le biais de
confirmation de l'hypothèse
on en parlera bientôt
non mais c'est il y a plein de petites choses et
si on ne se base que
sur nos observations
l'exemple le plus classique c'est de dire
que tous les cygnes sont blancs
alors qu'en fait pas du tout il ya des cygnes
noirs
mais tant qu'on a pas vu de cygnes noirs on
peut pas le savoir
je m'etends BREF
de manière plus concise
mon point de vue c'est que il faut qu'on couple ces observations avec
l'expérimentation
et ça ça se fait dans des labos et le
but c'est de trouver le juste milieu en
fait entre
ce qu'on trouve dans la nature et ce
qu'on trouve dans nos petits labo' chéris
j'avais fait une analyse du discours de
François Hollande et ce qui était
reproché de manière globale
pas certaines personnes c'était
de m'appuyer sur  rien de concret et de ne
pas sourcer en faite  la manière dont
dont je faisait les choses et
c'est assez rigolo parce qu'on peut
élargir sa à  plus grand en fait
on discutait un tout  petit peu avant de faire
la vidéo avec frederic
je disais moi quand j'ai lancé cette
chaîne je me suis jamais
placé en tant que vulgarisateur je me suis dit tiens
je vais dire ce que je connais
je veux parler de ce que je sais de ce
que j'aime et de ce que je fais sur
scène et hors scène
mais à aucun moment je me suis dit que
vous alliez appréhendés ça aussi  parfois
comme une vérité voir une vérité absolue
et ce qui n'est pas le cas en fait
et c est assez intéressant en fait de
pouvoir aussi aujourd'hui se dire
quand on m'amène des choses et des
réflexions différentes
ça me vexe pas au contraire .- ah non et c'est pour ça que je suis là d'ailleurs-.
:- ça l'aurait vexé je serai jamais venu!.-  c'est ça la différence  avec les vulgarisateurs
qui ne font que ça  c'est à dire qu'ils vont avoir le temps
de potassé le sujet et de lire tout ce
qu'il ya à ce sujet-là des
contradictions des confirmations
et puis de vous donner
ce que Rabelais appelait la substantifique moelle ce qui est très jolie
pour dire un condensé de tout et vous
donner
l'information telle quelle est de
manière
.-actuel ouais-. actuel et dans le consensus
aussi qu'on en a
ça sonnait très "Eddy Malou" tout ça! ,-ouais on a perdu
200 abonnés! - HA HA HA! "C'est le nom du papa
du savant de la république"
.- ah oui! c'est vrai! Je connais ce mec! Eddy Malou! Eddy si tu nous regarde!
ah mais je veux  faire une vidéo avec toi , enfin un long métrage du coup parce que ça risque d'être long quoi
en une phrase "ha ha ha"
mais voilà c'était important de dire ca
et comme je passe  ce temps-là et
cette exigence-là pour avoir ce
temps-là
dans ce rythme qu'est le
mentale blog je pars que sur ce que je
connais
sur ce quoi je me suis fait former à tort
ou à raison de toutes les formations
ne sont pas
n'ont pas office de vérité non
plus " ca on pourra y revenir"
et  également de ce que je
pratique donc de mon expérience
personnelle mais c'est pas une vérité
et elle est critiquable et je devrais
aujourd'hui
dans l'état actuel des choses peut-être sourcer un peu plus, aller rechercher un peu plus
ce sera sûrement le cas d'ailleurs l'année
prochaine mais toujours marquera qu'il y a
une évolution la chaîne qui tent vers ça
.-absolument! absolument! on eb
discutait d'ailleurs
on a remarqué que au fur et
à mesure des vidéos
il y a eu en fait  des vidéos
précision comme on peut les appeler
c'est-à-dire qu'il ya eu par exemple
une vie le "non-verbal"
et puis il y a eu l'importance de prendre en compte la "base line"
un seuil de références qui permet de
juger des micro-expressions faciale par
exemple
donc oui il ya une évolution
et aussi comme tu disais faire une vidéo par jour on n'a pas le
temps de lire tout ce qu'on peut lire
sur le sujet
et c'est pour ça que
c'est aussi notre tâche en tant que
vulgarisateur de pouvoir venir
vous donnez un autre point de vue en
fait
vous donnez un
un point de vue qui est différent mais
qui n'a pas office de vérité
par rapport à celui de Fabien et vice-versa .- je trouve que ce que  tu amènes là
en fait
c'est le conseil que ce soit moi ou
quelqu'un d'autre ou une formation ou
un article que vous lisez
gardez votre esprit critique ouvert et
ne prenez jamais rien pour argent
comptant, n'hésitez pas à faire vos
recherches par vous-même et à
réfléchir aussi à l'inverse
peut-être tu veux synthétiser ses pensés là .- oui en fait c'est euh..
alors c'est très complexe aujourd'hui
d'avoir un esprit critique
parce que quand on est bombardé d'entre
toutes la journée les réseaux sociaux
nous
inonde d'info
on n'a pas le temps de faire un tri
ce que je veux vous dire aussi c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui se
spécialisent dans le domaine et qui sont
tout à fait accessibles voilà,
vous nous envoyez un email
normalement dans les deux jours on vous
répond, on vous dis voilà "cette info est fiable"
"cette info n'est pas fiable" "cette info
est à vérifier"
c'est.. n'hésitez pas à prendre contact
en fait c'est..
c'est important aussi pour nous scientifiques .- quand tu dis "on" c'est?-.
mais "on" c'est.. il y a plusieurs
vulgarisateurs, je sais pas si je peux citer les noms?
.-Bah OUI!.-  on a
"la tronche-en-biais" qui s'occupe de
tout ce qui est biais
psychologique on a "signification"
qui travaille sur tout ce qui est
communication et communication
non-verbale plus spécifiquement
et puis on a toute une équipe d'hommes
de scientifiques
et plus spécifiquement de doctorants
qui travaille sur tout ce qui est
mensonge.. tout ce qui est
information en rapport avec
les méthodes de détections... de faux
souvenirs..
tout ce qui interrogatoire de polices..
donc on est plusieurs à pouvoir vous
répondre à ce sujet là et si ce n'est pas notre
spécialité on peut vous renvoyer vers quelqu'un autre
parce que oui on a du réseau
attention ILS sont partout
en fait c'est ça qui était intéressant
c'était de..
parfois dans les commentaires on peut penser
qui a des attaques et des fois c'est même
des abonnés qui disent : "ah mais he qu'es que vous faites et tout?" et moi qui essaie de calmer le
jeu
c'est.. alors parfois c'est attaques mais c'est
parce que là il faut de tout pour faire
un monde
mais en général c'est plutôt
bienveillant et c'est ou pour votre bien
aux pour voir où, moi, j'en suis moi
et ni les uns ni les autres, sommes en guerres
mais on le sait à partir du moment où
on peut en discuter ensemble. .- Absolument!
Absolument! -. mais ce qui n'était pas
forcément à fait avant puisque qu'on se répondait que
par commentaires
et c'était important pour moi de
proposer plein de fois, de faire une
vidéo et je suis content que tu viennes parce que là
je trouve
qu'il y a un poids aussi bien dans ce que
je dis parce que ça me permet de clarifier des
que dans ce que tu dis parce que
ça permet de comprendre des choses
et une forme de vigilance .-voilà-.
et en ça c'est cool voilà! .-je suis
content d'être là-.
.- bah moi aussi-.
alors on rappelle pour la chaîne de Frédéric la
chaîne c'est le: Le Mythologue
chaîne que tu as lancée il ya
quelques mois? semaines?
alors euh au moment où on fait cette
vidéo...
ça faiiiiit à  peu près un mois... un peu plus..
et attention on a cassé l'internet
on est à 285 abonnés!!!
CHAMPAGNE! c'est tout.. Champagne..!
dont moi!
dont lui!
dont Fabien qui était le premier! ( bouchon de champagne! bouchon de champagne!)
ou peut-être le deuxième
.- ouais je crois pas que j'étais le premier? mais j'ai tout de suite mis un abonnés en plus-- PLAAA!
.- Ouais ouais c'était :abonnés, bravo, champagne et tout..!
pour moi j'ai vu fabien dessus...j'étais là... c'est bon
.-ha ha ha! .- j'arrête! -.
j'fais une vidéo! j'arrête!
ma volonté c'est vraiment de faire
un contenu qui est
représentatif de ce qui se dit dans la
littérature scientifique
mais en attendant il faut que je le
mette à la disponibilité de tout le
monde et que je le rende
accessible
en mettant une touche d'humour en plus
et c'est de l'humour belge
vous voyez le complexe que ça fait en
fait
donc il me faut à peu près deux
semaines pour l'instant  et comme
j'édite je monte.. enfin  je fais tout
moi-même
ben voilà ça prend un peu de temps
donc une vidéo toutes les deux semaines sur la chaîne de Frédéric! Allez découvrir ça
je vous recommande, et c'est le lien aussi que je vais vous mettre,
la première vidéo sur la définition
du mensonge
parce que ça c'est intéressant avant
de vouloir parler de quelque chose de le
définir
donc je le recommandes vraiment les
vidéos sont fun
ça bravo!
Parce que il y a de la vraie recherche en écriture, elle se
regarde, ça passe crème! c'est super cool!
Merci à vous d'avoir regardé les
vidéos j'espère que sa vous a plus si
ça vous a plus, pensez aussi a vous abonner à la chaîne si ce n'est pas déjà
fait
à celle
de notre ami Frédéric et le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an du
1er janvier au 31 décembre donc, rendez-vous
demain! Oui Madame! tous les jours à
17 heures CIAO